thanks uh it's great to be here with all
of you today I'm going to talk about
publishing Jupiter notebooks with quarto
um before I get into quarto and
Publishing I want to reflect a little
bit on kind of the nature and purpose
and value of of Jupiter notebooks and
for those of you who are users of
Jupiter notebooks or consumers of
Jupiter notebooks I think it's really
instructive to read a paper that came
out a couple years ago from Brian
Granger and Fernando Perez who sort of
the two folks who who created a lot of
the the modern Jupiter notebook
ecosystem and they talk about the
breadth of things that Jupiter
represents certainly it represents an
interactive Computing environment it
represents a file format it represents a
community and a set of projects but they
really if you look at the title of the
talk they really focus on this idea of
Jupiter helping humans to think and tell
stories with code and data and I think
this is really a profoundly important
part of of what Jupiter is and if you
think about the times just on the on the
on the creative side on the analytical
side when you write about what you're
going to what you're going to code it
actually changes what you're going to
code but clarifying what you're doing
and why through writing helps actually
affects the work so that's kind of on
the on the production side
but also on the side of the consumer of
data products or or analytics some of
you may have seen the pamphlet that
Edward tufty wrote which has sort of
takedown of this sort of reductive style
of PowerPoint slides but you could
equally make the same comment about some
dashboards where we're just spitting out
very simple overviews of things outside
of a lot of contextual information a lot
of assumptions constraints
um again contextual information and
really and he points out there are
several very significant and important
decisions including the launch of the
the failed launch of the Space Shuttle
that if they had the benefit of more
rigorous presentation of analytics may
not have happened so the sort of idea of
tools for data storytelling which of
which Jupiter represents a huge
component of are really important
um there's there's quite a bit of
History to these tools uh and in fact
they go all the way back to work on Tech
and literate programming the idea of
weaving together code and content and
they go all the way back to the first
interactive notebooks uh and so there's
been lots of work that's going on in
literate programming notebooks markdown
systems and this work has been happening
in parallel and I think in many ways in
the last few years it's coming together
in a way that creates an incredibly
compelling kind of tool chain and
environment for doing storytelling with
data
so now a little bit more about quarto I
am the founder and CEO of posit which
you probably haven't heard of um the
company used to be called rstudio which
we may have may have been more likely to
have heard of a man at our studio I
worked on the r Studio IDE I worked on a
system called our markdown and I worked
on a bunch of R interfaces to other
systems including Python and Keras
tensorflow spark and so we actually uh I
worked on our markdown quite a bit and
started working on that actually over 10
years ago and that was a similar kind of
data storytelling literate programming
system but unfortunately that system was
very successful and we saw people
benefit a lot from it but it was sort of
Trapped in the r ecosystem and so I was
really not happy with that and I really
wanted to make to take a lot of the
ideas we had developed there and and
sort of rewrite everything from the
ground up to be multi-language and
multi-engine and based on Jupiter so
that's kind of what the Cordo project
represents
um and this is a diagram this is the
kind of the basic mechanic of Cordo I'll
show this two or three times during the
talk at different levels of depth and
specificity but fundamentally you have a
set of computations that are done in
Jupiter those computations are
transformed into markdown the markdown
is processed by a system called pandok
which we'll get into a little bit later
and out of that comes lots of different
types of production quality output
including documents presentations web
pages or even things like websites blogs
and books
so in this talk I kind of want to cover
the core ideas behind Cordo and the core
motivations behind it kind of what's
significant about the system and what
are the most important things to pay
attention to so we'll talk a little more
about computational narratives
we'll talk about the specific
requirements around technical
Communications
um we'll talk about the value of
semantic authoring right once published
everywhere uh we'll get into a little
bit of the debate some of the debate
around notebooks and what's good about
them what's bad about them what are the
mitigations for for things that are that
are not so good about them and then a
little bit about how the system works
and how you can extend it so we'll start
with a little more about computational
narratives and I think
quarto represents a tool for doing
computational narratives and we've
actually already talked about a bunch of
these core requirements you know Jupiter
technical contents using markdown lots
of different output formats so there are
actually a bunch of tools that do that
and in fact NB convert you may be
familiar with if you're a Jupiter user
that's been around for a long long time
but more recently there are tools
including Cordo as well as Jupiter book
Miss JS that have do quite a bit more
than NB convert support quite a bit more
flexibility and output support things
like websites and books so in this talk
I'm going to talk about this this genre
of tools through the lens of Cordo but I
think it's important to recognize that a
lot of these tools do share a lot of
features and they're definitely all
worth evaluating
all right so back to our original
Mechanic we'll get a little more depth
about how Corto Works cordo's invoked by
saying render you render a notebook
um
we start with a Jupiter notebook now
that Jupiter notebook uh may have
already been executed you may have
executed the cells interactively while
you worked in the notebook or you may
want to re-execute all the cells for you
know reproducibility or freshness of
data so you start with a notebook either
executed or not
um I'll show this in a minute you add a
bunch of options to the notebook to
condition what it what output is
produced and specifically how it's
produced
and then we do quarto render and we get
the desired output format so
I want to talk before I get into kind of
the more depth about how all that works
I want to make a comment about pandok
that's a really important part of the
chain and pandok actually is is a kind
of a universal document converter that's
been around for almost 20 years uh it
was created by John McFarland who's one
of the main if not the main kind of
principal person in the markdown
community in terms of standardization
um
pandok represents common Mark which is a
base standard plus many extensions for
technical writing it actually supports
dozens of output formats just formats
you've never heard of but are still
nevertheless important just about any
format you could name and for us most
importantly it's very extensible it's
very hackable you can write custom
readers custom writers custom document
Transformers and so for building
Advanced features it's really it's
really unmatched as a platform all right
so let's let's take a look at again the
basic mechanic this slide I'll show you
something you've seen before it won't be
particularly remarkable but I wanted to
sort of establish it as a baseline
here's a notebook on the left it just
reads some data and plots it just in
Jupiter lab and here's the quarto render
of that notebook is essentially just an
HTML transformation straightforward no
options again you've probably seen from
NB convert and other tools exactly this
done before so what do we how do we
enhance the presentation or condition
the presentation of things well we add
options so here I'm actually I've added
a yaml options block to the same
notebook where I've said I want to use a
different theme I want to use a
different highlight style and I want to
add a feature I want to add commenting
using the hypothesis engine to the
document so now when I render this
document you can see it's got obviously
a different theme different fonts a
different highlighting style and on on
the far right you can see it's added a
commenting bar so that's the the basic
mechanic is you you put a bunch of
options in yaml and there are literally
depending on the format you know for
PDFs there's actually over 100 options
for for HTML there's dozens of options
so there's lots of options to condition
things I'm just sort of showing you for
example here some of them so that's
document level options there's also cell
level options so here here I'm kind of
showing both I'm going to put some
document level options that uh that
condition how code is presented and then
on the cell you can see I put a special
comment uh using this Hash Pipe syntax
um to say I would like to make my figure
a cross-referenceable and I want to use
this as a caption so now when I render
this document you can see the code is
actually collapsed you can see there's a
Code menu in the it's code tools code
tools menu up in the top right corner
and then you can see that the figure
indeed does have a caption and is indeed
cross-referenceable you can see the link
see figure one if I click that code menu
you'll see that it there's a way for me
to expand all the code or hide all the
code so this is just showing that as you
add layer in more options the documents
that you produce become kind of more and
more interesting
um and I think this underscores
hopefully you've seen a little bit again
you've seen converting a notebook to a
web page that's totally trivial that's
that's done by many many many tools
um and it's done by NB convert well
really we're trying to go beyond that
we're trying to give you
professional stunningly good looking
production quality output and do it in a
ton of different formats so yes web
pages but also office documents PDFs
presentations aggregate formats like
books and blogs uh interfacing with
content Management Systems so that's
really kind of what's what's distinct
when you think about quarto versus a
sort of a just a straightforward
document conversion system so a couple
examples of that here we're going to say
we'd like to convert The Notebook to a
word doc just by saying format docx we
get the word doc and again there's
things in this word doc that would be a
little bit challenging to do just with
word like like syntax code syntax
highlighting or even just placing two
plots side by side in a panel but that's
done automatically um don't
automatically by quarto another example
we'll look at making a PDF and one thing
that's we'll get into this in a little
bit as well so look talking about some
other features but the optimum reading
width
um for print is somewhere around four
and a half to five inches is wide which
is not the whole page in the optimum
reading width for web is somewhere
between 650 and 700 pixels so actually
in most cases it leaves room in the
margins and you would like to make use
of the margin so in this case we're
going to say we want to put our site our
citations in the margin and when we show
a you know figure with two plots side by
side we actually want to use the entire
page for it we don't want to be limited
to the width of the text so you can see
in making this PDF we've got the
citation in the margin as well as the
both the code and the plot kind of
overflowing the main text column so
there are lots of things like this you
can do for more sophisticated use of the
entire page with with some of these
options there's a whole I will not
actually be able to get to it in a lot
of depth today but there's a whole
presentation system inside quarto that
has a lot of features this presentation
itself was was created with quarto here
I'm just going to say I'm going to take
my notebook and turn it into a slide
deck and specify a logo and slide slide
numbering so you can see here it's just
gonna in in the case I have two plots
they're placed side by side on the on
the on the slide there's a logo and you
can see the the numbering
um now this is for presenting data but
you also might want to some
presentations we give in the technical
environment are about code and trying to
explain how code works so here's another
variation where we basically say we do
want to show the code this time and we
actually want to highlight specific line
numbers for explanation so here you can
see the slide has the code as well as
the plot and you can see uh the line
four is highlighted you can see in code
line numbers it's going to first
highlight line four and when I Advance
the slide it's actually going to
highlight line five so this is very good
when you want to explain code there's a
lot of tools for doing that
um so far I have shown you examples of
single documents but quarto also has a
project system which lets you create
compound you know sets of documents and
sets of documents might be collected
together as a website as a Blog as a
book and to create projects you create
you use this quarter yaml file that file
defines a type in this case website some
options for that type in this case some
simple navbar options and then some
common settings for documents produced
within the project here we're saying use
the cosmo theme and apply the following
CSS file to all the content in the
project so some real world examples of
quarto projects this is the website for
the fast AI uh practical deep learning
for coders website you can see it has
the basics but it also has some social
metadata has some links back to GitHub
repo has some customization of the
navbar and the sidebar and you can see
rendered this is the website you can see
all the kind of navigation all the
lessons on the left the table of
contents on the right the link back to
GitHub the nav bar so lots and lots of
options for customizing how websites
actually look and how navigation Works
inside them
blogs are a special type of website this
is the yaml file looks somewhat similar
to the the fast AI one has a bunch of
Social Links and GitHub links but it
also has some some customizations of the
navbar and some additional customization
for the Twitter card and you can see
this presents as a Blog which has a you
know tiled display of different blog
articles and navigable categories
um
and here's an example of a book uh this
again has some some similarities but it
also has a cover image it has a list of
chapters and you can see when the book
is rendered it has some different things
it has numbered chapters it has numbered
sections it has uh when you see figure
3.6 you can actually do cross references
across chapters using numbering so
different things going on with a book
and I should specifically mention for
books HTML books are very interesting
and useful but um books actually can
produce there's actually five different
book formats including latex word ePub
and ASCII Doc and ASCII Doc's
particularly useful for submitting books
to O'Reilly or or Manning that's their
their sort of their their base tool
chains work off of Esky doc
so we're definitely seeing a lot of
people write technical books uh with
quarto using these tools
okay let's talk a little bit about
um the the particular requirements of
technical communication and I want to
First reflect on the fact that the the
typical tools you use keynote or
PowerPoint or Google Docs or word don't
technical content is really an
afterthought you can see Google just
announced code blocks and Google Docs
like three three months ago three or
four months ago so um there's a lot of
things you need to do when you present
technical content code is one of the
things
figures is another thing I've shown some
examples of that citations and
cross-references but there's also math
and there's also diagrams and there's
also more sophisticated use of the page
to because you're not just presenting
narrative you're really trying to get
people to understand things at a high
level of depth and nuance and so doing
things with margins and using call outs
all very important
all not very well supported by
conventional Document authoring Systems
so as an example for source code
presentation here I want to explain some
source code and so you can see on the
right I actually have one two three
parts of the source code that I want to
explain and those are linked to items at
the bottom that explain them the way you
do that in markdown is to just say okay
this is the first thing I want to
explain and then you have a list below
that says here's the text that's
associated with that similarly the
second thing and similarly the third
thing so this is just one example there
are many many there's an entire article
about how to customize codeblock
presentation in quarto in terms of
syntax highlighting behaviors like
copying code blocks folding code code
annotation there's lots and lots of
things you can do adding line numbers to
make to make presentation of code really
effective in in quarter documents
um
mentioned diagrams uh you probably a
good number of people in this room are
familiar with the fact that you can
write diagrams using plain text there's
actually two major systems for that uh
or at least two systems supported by
quarto one is graphiz which has been
around for decades and the other is
mermaid which is a little more
contemporary it's actually that mermaids
actually supported natively on GitHub so
you define your diagram in text you can
see it's in a code block that looks
similar to like a python code block and
then the diagram is rendered by the
rendering engine this is actually quite
a bit nicer way to write diagrams than
than clicking and dragging many people
have found so quarter natively supports
diagrams
um equations again many of you have
probably seen latex equations
um the latex equations work very well in
all formats so they get typeset whether
they be you know typeset into a PDF or
turn into mathml for word docs or turn
into math Jacks for web presentation
equations are handled handled very well
also and we've talked we've shown a
couple demonstrations of figures and
cross references here I'm going to
create sub figures which is a little bit
of a variation so I have two
side-by-side figures that are sub
figures and when I render this you can
see the subfigures have captions they
can be referred to you can see in the
top right figure 1B
um and all that all this numbering and
things of figures has done is done
automatically
so that's also often quite important
figure panels figure cross references
figure numbering for technical content
uh and then citations I won't go into a
lot of depth here other than to say that
the pandok has very robust support for
citations and in fact I had no idea that
there were I probably would have guessed
there's a couple hundred ways to render
citations turns out there's ten thousand
so those are all all supported uh by
pandok
uh and then call outs you've seen these
in content that you've consumed around
the web there's a sort of a simple
markdown syntax you can see on the left
for callouts and these are supported in
many I think eight or nine different
formats
um the the callouts end up getting
rendered kind of in a way that looks
natively good in all those different
formats
um and then I mentioned before use of
margins again sometimes you have a main
narrative and you don't want to burden
the main narrative with all kinds of
ancillary information but you still want
the information available for those that
care so here I'm going to show placing
content in the margin and then placing a
figure in the margin and then also
placing a table in the margin you don't
see all everything in the notebook that
drives that but what you get at the end
is again use of margin for a note and an
equation and the use of the margin for a
figure and a table
um the other thing that happens is again
we have this natural reading width that
uh that we want our documents to conform
to but sometimes we have visualizations
that really want to take be full bleed
or take up the whole page here I have a
panel of four plots I really don't want
that confined to the main content region
so here I can say I'd like this to go
into a column so the column could be
screen or page or some kind of outset
here I'm saying
have it occupy the whole screen and have
it be inset a little bit with shading so
here we can take full advantage of the
width of the either printed or uh our
web page
but still keep our content in a
comfortable reading width so that's use
of margins
okay a little more about this idea of of
semantic authoring and I think I can
illustrate what semantic authoring is in
two ways uh first I can talk a little
bit about what literal authoring is
which we're all familiar with which is
we write documents in the native editor
and format for a given purpose and many
of us have probably used latex uh people
many of us use word or Google Docs
content Management Systems like
Confluence presentation tools so litter
authoring is kind of the most popular uh
form of authoring but it does come with
some limitations most foremost of which
is that each of these ends up with their
own proprietary format and repurposing
content across mediums especially in an
automated fashion is quite time
consuming and challenging and even
inconsistent these tools tend to not
have a lot of support for technical
content and certainly don't support Live
code and its output these are mostly
content authoring tools they're not
computational tools and therefore
there's not a really great way to
automate and reproduce computationally
derived content so that's automated in
terms of producing multiple types of
content from the same source and also
producing content that's driven by
computations so if we look at semantic
authoring most all of you have probably
seen markdown I don't need to explain
what markdown is but that's really
markdown is the quintessential example
of semantic authoring we say I want a
heading I want a strong text I want a
code block I want to block quote and
then some renderer will figure out
exactly what that means in a given in a
given setting
um most critically though with semantic
authoring the document is actually
parsed into what's called an AST or an
abstract syntax tree that actually can
be computed on so this is actually the
key to supporting all these features in
Corridor and all these output formats is
that we're going to parse this not it's
not it's not we're not dealing with the
docx or or HTML we're dealing with this
abstract representation of what a
document is and now we can Implement all
kinds of features on top of that and
support all kinds of different output
formats and that's kind of the most
important thing about how cortos and
pandok are able to to do all the things
they're able to do
um so in the case of Jupiter again
Jupiter is getting its executed content
and markdown cells over into pandok
which again at the pandok layer we
translate it into this document AST
we use a bunch of Transformations on the
AST to implement all these features that
we've talked about uh and then finally
we render the final output from the AST
so that's kind of how semantic authoring
works with Jupiter Jupiter ultimately
gets reduced into markdown and goes into
the rest of the system and so pandok
then actually supports I'm not even
showing you all the formats it supports
it supports dozens of output formats the
obvious ones you've you've heard of and
think of
um but also there's multiple types of
presentation there's multiple flavors of
markdown there's multiple flavors of
wikis that it can produce and then
there's other formats you may not have
heard of you may not have heard of jats
or ASCII doc but those are really really
fundamentally important to a bunch of of
publishing pipelines so by by authoring
semantically and getting all of our
content into this Universal form we can
produce content kind of in whatever form
we need
um and an example of that is kind of how
you can use quarto with content
Management Systems so many of you may be
in companies or part of producing
content that's managed by a system like
Hugo or duckasaurus or you produce
content for uh Confluence
um these are these are formats that
actually were not built into pandok but
we were able to use the extensibility of
pandok custom writers and filters to
make it so you can transform notebooks
and kind of quarto mark down into these
formats so here's an example this is our
same original hello world notebook and
in this case we're gonna we've we've put
the notebook inside a Hugo uh website
and it actually gets rendered in the
sort of style of of the Hugo website
um here we're creating goldmark markdown
which is the specific markdown flavor
that Hugo speaks in the case of
dacosaurus they have their own flavor of
markdown called MDX markdown when we
render the note we stick our notebook
inside the docosaurus site and we render
it it looks like docosaurus it uses
their native flavor of markdown and it
uses their native rendering and theming
and all that sort of thing similarly
with Confluence Confluence doesn't speak
markdown or or really HTML it's it
speaks its own XML format but because
again we can compute on the document AST
because it's going to be we've we've
authored in a universal fashion we can
take that same notebook and we could
have it published into into a Confluence
Confluence Wiki and then I've alluded to
this before
um by being able to produce ASCII doc we
can put our books into the O'Reilly
Atlas publishing publishing system which
they then use to create print versions
of books web versions of books ePub
versions of books and similarly Manning
also uses ASCII doc so this is just
giving you example we we added all these
formats to pandok using the
extensibility mechanisms so whatever
system or format you need your to
publish your notebooks or content in
it's almost certainly going to be
possible
okay uh let's talk a little bit more
about Jupiter notebooks and many of you
have probably seen or heard of this talk
uh from Joe Cruz I don't like notebooks
and many of you have probably seen the
Jeremy Howard's response to uh I like
notebooks um so it's obvious to say
there's a lot of controversy about the
nature of notebooks are they a good
Computing environment you know are they
are they good for us are they bad for us
um I think wherever you come down on all
of that
um I think it's hard to deny the fact
that they are certainly in terms of
communicating about data they're the
coin of the realm um it's incredibly
useful to have a standard format and
container for code output and related
narrative this ipin B format that is a
universal publishing format it has many
different editors you can publish both
statically like you see notebooks on
GitHub you can publish interactively
like when you publish a notebook to
Kegel or collab
um and they again also are a source of
content for embedding in other documents
everything that's in a notebook is
programmatically addressable because
it's a Json file so um
specifically as an authoring tool there
are tons of different notebook front
ends I've just listed five of them and
they all interoperate with each other
that's incredibly useful
some of the critique of notebooks has to
do with the fact that they are just this
Json blob and
they're hard to diff you have to use a
specialized editor you can't use a text
editor it's also important to note that
there's a package called jupitxt and
they're actually no less than 10
different plain text formats for
notebooks supported in jupitxt five
different markdown formats that you can
transform notebooks to and from and five
different versions of my notebook is a
DOT Pi file so I think you know
coalescing around this standard has even
allowed us to to create lots of really
compelling plain text formats that
benefit from the whole notebook
ecosystem you'll notice in the bottom
left we talk about quarto markdown we
have a variation of notebooks in the
quarto system that is a plain text file
and so the the qmd file is essentially a
plain text version of a notebook so if
you prefer to use your favorite Text
Editor to edit if you prefer to have all
the cells always run in the same order
if you want your work to integrate well
with Version Control these are these
essentially some of these fundamental
problems get solved when you use the
text the text based representation of
notebooks I think there are pros and
cons I think there's different
situations and contexts and constraints
that would lead you to use an IPI and B
versus qmd use the best tool for the job
in a given situation but qmd is is along
with ipin B is very well supported in
quarto
um but here I'm just going to run
through sort of showing you that all the
same things you see in a notebook are in
the qmd file I won't dwell on that we
have a vs code extension that's very
good at editing qmd files there's also a
really nice neovim mode that's available
um and it does the things you'd expect
syntax highlighting and completion lets
you run things cell by cell and you can
see it has a lot of the sort of same
idea of a notebook but all in plain text
so this is just to make the point that
uh using Jupiter as sort of this common
point of standards for output and
execution is really useful and we can
use node IP notebooks or not use ipmp
notebooks and still benefit from Jupiter
um another scenario is the using
notebooks as a Content source so this
idea that when you've created an ipin B
file it has figures and related code and
explanation or tables or other
computations and you may not want to
publish that it may there may be
hundreds of lines of code there may be
research notes and things you don't want
to publish but you still want to extract
the actual visualizations or other other
uh forms of data presentation so we have
a way to do that so if you have a
notebook you can embed cells from the
notebooks into a larger document so here
you can see this is a qmd file in vs
code that actually has this embed in it
so when I render this it's actually
going to pull the figure out of the
notebook and stick it into the rendered
document you can see what that looks
like you can see the render document you
can see the figure that's been pulled
out of the notebook and actually
critically there are links back to the
notebook so you can see at a global
level you can see these are these are
the notebooks used by this article or
report and then at the figure level it's
here's the source for this figure so in
many cases we want to have all this
extra context we want to have all this
extra code we certainly don't want to
present it to all of our readers here's
a way of allowing readers who want to
know more or inspect more uh be able to
do that I want to actually navigate to
inside the notebook you can see I get
sort of an HTML representation of the
notebook and all the code and narrative
and also the ability to uh to download
The Notebook if I want to
um we're actually working closely with
folks from Jupiter book and Miss js on a
standard for doing this sort of thing
for scientific Publications and the idea
is to make notebooks actually a part of
the scientific record and a part of peer
review so we're working hard to kind of
drive a lot of Standards around
notebooks so they become a standard uh
part of the way people communicate and
do science
okay I'm a little bit under the hood
just a little bit about how the systems
can be kind of extended and hacked
um
a little bit about how we interface with
Jupiter kernels uh we execute all code
cells using Jupiter you can use any
Jupiter kernel you want I've seen
actually bash kernel C kernel APL kernel
all used
um Python and Julia are the most widely
used and we've got some tricks to make
sure sometimes this kernel startup time
can be long especially some versions of
Julia can be over 30 seconds and so we
keep the kernel alive so that we get
kind of interactive response times as we
re-render documents so fundamentally we
mostly use Jupiter kernels it's
important to note that execution engines
are actually an extensibility point in
Cordo so there are other engines besides
Jupiter that are possible in fact we
have one other engine which is the
Knitter engine which gives us
compatibility with our markdown
documents but we may add other engines
in the future I know there are a couple
of notebook systems in Julia that we've
talked to folks about creating custom
engines for so we want we kind of want
all of the infrastructure around
document production again to be
independent of language and even
independent system even so Jupiter is
the the predominant execution system
used now
um there's a lot you can do about
controlling the execution of cells if
you're authoring directly in Jupiter lab
or ipin B you can decide exactly when
code execution occurs you can execute
something and then not execute it for
another month if it takes three hours to
run you want to leave it alone that's
fine you can do sort of full top to
bottom execution of qmd files so you
sort of have reproducibility and
consistency that does create the need
for some caching and there are a couple
different strategies for caching which I
won't go into a lot of detail about now
but there's a Jupiter cache project and
then we have a feature called free so
there's different ways to make sure that
if computations are expensive they're
not always in the way of of content
rendering
really important part of the system is
filters
we take we have that sort of abstract
representation of the document that gets
computed upon and filters are what does
the Computing and they can be used to do
all kinds of things generate content
modify content remove content produce
Target format specific output so I'll
just give you a brief example using the
Pan Flute Library this is a filter that
simply takes any heading that is level
one to five and bumps The Heading level
up by one you can see at the top we
render the notebook and we say we would
like to use this filter the full source
code for the filter is below and you can
see the real work is being done by this
one statement that checks for headings
that are again levels one through five
and bumps they're heading level up but
you can imagine all sorts of things you
might do with filters
including you can have embedded
languages that's how we implement the
the diagramming features that we that we
showed before macro substitution again
cross-referencing citations
image conversion filtering compression
transformation Advanced formatting using
the margins call outs lots of things you
can do with filters
and that's really how we Implement a lot
of the quarto features but you can add
your own filters so any feature that you
wish Cordo had you can almost certainly
implement it with a filter so there's
just some examples of filters that that
folks have created lightbox filter for
doing lightbox treatments chemistry
specific one molestar one's for
embedding QR codes more fine-grained
presentation of code so lots and lots of
examples of filters you can actually
write filters there's a couple pan
python libraries for writing filters
and there's an embedded Lua interpreter
if you want to write filters that have
no dependencies and then you can
actually write filters in any language
you want using a Json representation of
the AST so lots of different ways to
write filters
filters are sort of part of our
extension system there's other types of
extensions that are possible which we
talk about on our site filters being I'd
say the principal one but there's also
short codes which are sort of like
content generating macros you can write
your own formats and so like for example
the Hugo docosaurus and Confluence
formats work we used our custom format
API to create those people have created
custom formats for for Journal articles
people have created custom formats for
like themed versions of reveal.js
presentations that match like their
their sort of corporate corporate look
and theme and you can create sort of
different new types of projects and
project templates so lots of different
things to do with extensions
um so that's the example of kind of
hacking the system from within what can
you do to uh to change the way the
system behaves inside itself but you can
also integrate it's a open source CLI
tools you can integrate it with other
tools and Tool chains one example of
this is uh nbdev which many of you have
probably heard of which is a tool for
interactively developing python packages
Within Jupiter it automatically creates
tests publishes does CI and in version
two of nbdev it will publish a
documentation website for your package
using quarto so as an example of sort of
embedding quarto in a broader tool chain
so thank you
[Music]